This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences
essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the health and dependents. Construise a career enriching to service
of the community francophone of all the country. Don't the quality in French, it's possible
with the City. Visit Collage LaC. .A. today, An initiative of the Consortium National
of Formation in Health Supposed by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the woman that saw the murder
take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey
toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS.
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Chichariot-O-Nand-es,
and listen to learning to be human. on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Your husband is not who you think he is. Your body is not what you thought it was. Your identity is formed by a secret history. I'm Danny Shapiro. And these are just a few of the stunning stories I'll be exploring on the 14th season of Family Secrets.
He kind of shoved me out of the way and said, move. And he went out the front door and he jumped in a car and drove off. And that was the last time I saw him. Listen to Season 14 of Family Secrets. secrets on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody. I'm Jemma Spake, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast.
It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology. of our 20s. So a few weeks ago, I saw this book in the window at a secondhand bookstore in Amsterdam called The Psychology of Superstition. It was like, you know, when you see a book and it's like calling to you, it was calling to me. I'm a deeply superstitious person, have been since I was a kid. I immediately bought it and I kind of put the question out to you guys, the listeners, asking if you wanted to hear an episode on it and all that you. of you said, yes, absolutely, we do. So this is that episode. Superstitious behaviors, as I learned from this book, show up in basically every single culture across every single time period
that humans have been alive for. They are an unspoken part of the fabric of humanity. And it turns out they are more psychological than you would think. They're also a lot less about actually controlling outcomes and creating good luck and more about emotional regulation and anxiety management. When we perform superstitious rituals, something deeply calming actually occurs in our minds that we can see and we can observe. Not only that, they also connect us deeply to others. They create self-fulfilling prophecies because they unconsciously influence our behavior, and they may even have a little bit of an evolutionary purpose. There are also some downsides to our superstitious beliefs that we're going to talk about as well. Their relationship to conspiracy theories is one of
them, how they intersect with OCD and anxiety to name a few others. But ultimately, I think having rituals, small superstitions, small practices that you do to mentally protect yourself or help yourself is for most people an incredibly valuable thing to have, whether you're in your 20s and beyond. And the science says it may actually help you live a more successful life to believe in something bigger than you. So we're going to talk about exactly why that is, according to some fascinating research, plus some really interesting superstitious rituals from across the world that you may want to try. Without further ado, let's get into it.
So what is superstition, really? Because I think you'd be surprised how many everyday things we do actually have superstitious origins. So superstition is usually defined as like any belief that a particular action, object, symbol or coincidence can can and will influence outcomes in a way that goes beyond ordinary cause and effect. In other words, superstition links things that are objectively not connected so that they feel connected, often through some mystical, otherworldly, maybe even religious, calmic force. So great example, classic example is like touching wood after saying something you're hoping for that you don't want to happen, so not to jinx things. Unconsciously avoiding
saying like, oh, I feel excited or I feel good about this thing if it hasn't had. happened yet because that feels like your tempting fate. Maybe you wear the same earrings to every job interview or every first day, even though they don't actually rationally influence the outcome, you're superstitious about it. Or you keep a lucky charm in your bag. You blow on dice. You don't want to step on the cracks, not walking under ladders because you think it's going to kind of curse you. Things that are objectively not related to the superstitious outcome, but that we still do. And these tiny rituals that might initially seem really insignificant, so much so that they don't even count for anything, but you still do them. You still involuntarily find yourself knocking on wood,
not walking under ladders, saying a prayer when you see a black cat. So there's this concept called half belief that was first spoken about in a paper published in 2024. And it talks about how many people, probably like you, practice superstitious things or practice superstitions, even though they don't believe in them, because of how woven they are into human history and consciousness. In this paper across two samples of participants, nearly half of these participants practiced some kind of superstitious belief or behavior, even though the majority of them was not convinced that it was actually real. So when they were asked, do you think this actually does anything, most of them would say no, but they still did it anyway. Even if rationally we don't
believe or don't have evidence that these things work, superstitious behaviors, again, are a deeply reoccurring human event that are part of our collective consciousness. When you look at some of the oldest, most significant superstitions, that is when we can kind of see why they are so psychologically significant and therefore have survived for so long. Take, for example, displaying the evil eye. This is actually a 5,000-year-old superstition originating in like Mesopotonia, in the Mediterranean, and it basically says that when people are jealous or envious of you, this can actually poison our own good fortune. So by wearing an evil eye amulet, which I'm sure you see everywhere these days, by displaying that blue eye charm, this almost reversed.
versus like the curse back on the person who is thinking negatively about you and kind of strikes them down with their own envious thoughts. Nowadays, everywhere, every jewelry shop, every, like, every girl has one of these necklaces. But anthropological works suggest that people have been displaying some version of the evil eye, of this evil eye, for thousands of years, beginning with these amulets that they were finding in Egypt and in Greece, this belief has been passed down through so many generations because it maps onto a lot of aspects of social psychology, in that things like envy and things like social threat have always mattered for our survival. So we employ the use of symbols as protection to manage the sense of vulnerability
that we have psychologically around people who may wish us harm. The second example is Friday the 13th, and this is another explanation for why and how superstitions come to be. The origin of this is very tangled. It's like a myth of religious, mythological, historical events. The first, I think, notion that Friday the 13th might be a bit of a cursed date was because of the Last Supper, Judas, was the 13th guest at the last supper. It occurred on the, I think on Friday the 13th. I don't really know. That was like the first, I guess, inclination that like this date might be cursed. Other writers have linked 13 to Norse mythology, particularly the story of Loki, arriving as an unwelcome extra guest, bringing chaos and death. That explanation is historically a little bit harder to pin down. Another reason why people think Friday
the 13th maybe a cursed date is because of there's been a lot of the occasions and historical events that have happened on this date. Yes, also obviously the crucifixion, but also a number of just like random things that don't seem interconnected or relevant to each other except for that they all shared this day. So there was a very famous bombing of Buckingham Palace that fell on Friday the 13th. The death of many significant figures has happened on Friday the 13th. This shows the second way that, you know, superstitions come to be through repetition, through layers and layers of stories and history that over time create superstition purely because of repeated association. Another example that explains the final way that superstitious beliefs come to be is knocking
on wood, which is one that I find myself unconsciously doing all the time. One of the most common theories links it back to ancient pagan beliefs, particularly in part of Europe, where trees were kind of thought to house spirits, gods, protective, supernatural forces. In that view, when you touch a tree or later just wood itself, it was like your way of asking for protection and showing reverence or, like, quietly calling on those forces for help. It may have also come from a child's game called Tiki Tiki Touchwood, where when you touch a piece of wood, you'd be safe from capture, you'd be safe from being. it. We have a game like this in Australia called Home Base where I guess like when you touch the
stump of wood, the guard is protecting like you win the game. Like there's a guard next to a stump of wood or a center piece of wood and everybody's running around trying to get it. Before this episode, I had absolutely no idea that that's where this tradition comes from. Yet every time I say something good or a wish or a desire or even when I say something bad that could happen and I don't want it to happen, I touch wood. And this just goes to show that over time, even as older religious or mythological beliefs die down and aren't necessarily something that we've been taught, the behavior still remains. It's been absorbed into our everyday group thinking. And those are three of the kind of ways that superstitions become global phenomena or become communal
phenomena. The big psychological question is why? Why do some things become superstitions that are seemingly random and others don't? Like why do we knock wood and knock glass? Why do our brains randomly find certain things comforting even if there is no solid evidence to them or just as much evidence for one thing over the other? One of the biggest factors behind superstition is pattern recognition. superstitions often begin just really randomly with a kind of like a few examples of where, you know, someone has displayed the evil eye and happened to experience prosperity. Someone has knocked on wood and has been protected maybe just out of coincidence.
People start noticing and putting together these coincidences. And that's what gives what are seemingly random things an association and a significant. our brain only then sees the examples that confirm our beliefs or confirm our superstitions, ignoring the ones that don't, because the pattern is so comforting, it creates order. Human brains are built to predict what will happen next in order to protect us, and they are constantly trying to connect events, infer causes, detect regularities, to live up to that mechanism or to fulfill that desire. Most of the time that is useful. It helps us to learn what effects have what outcomes.
But it also means that we are vulnerable to finding patterns in often complete randomness, just because our need for safety, predictability, security demanded of us. A rather old paper from 2008 from researchers at the University of Texas found that when people felt a lack of control, That is when they were more likely to perceive illusory patterns, which included leaning into conspiracies or leaning into superstitious thinking. When things feel confusing, uncertain, scary, this paper showed that the brain often prefers having any explanation, even if it doesn't have evidence for it, even if it cannot fully rationally explain why two things are linked.
it just needs something to grab onto. That same logic appears in research on illusory control. Griffiths and colleagues in their paper found that people with stronger superstitious beliefs also showed stronger perceptions of control in situations that were actually determined by chance. So what this means is that in ambiguous settings, some people are more likely to over-emphasize the fact that certain behaviors they've done mattered. They see themselves as more central because of their superstitions. A charm, a ritual, a phrase, a certain seat choice, a certain angel number. It starts to feel meaningful because the mind is attempting to reduce ambiguity to make us
feel internally safe. This is also where gut feelings come in. Sometimes superstitions arrive more so as sensations or feelings, kind of like a bit of tension that we feel or a sense that something is off or a pull towards a certain choice. It feels, superstition feels more like that. Listening to those things is what makes us superstitious rather than specific rituals. Gut feelings happen because the brain is constantly scanning for patterns beneath conscious awareness, such as these ones. We know this from so many episodes we've talked about it in. It takes in so much information. We cannot deliberately think about it all in once. Past experiences, emotional memories,
subtle environmental cues, microsocial signals, bodily feelings. We just can't think about it at the same time. And so it compresses all of that into a singular feeling that may be a gut instinct. Sometimes that feeling is genuinely useful. It can reflect real learning. Like, when we see a, I don't know, a slight momentary look on someone's face. And because of past experiences, we remember that, ha, the person who betrayed us in the past once had a similar look. And so even if their true intentions are overtly obvious, we get a gut feeling that something's amiss, that's a helpful situation or that's a helpful cue. But in situations of uncertainty, stress, fear, that same system can become oversensitive. The brain starts trying to
protect us not just from real danger like that shady person, but just from the sense of ambiguity itself. This is increased 100, if not a million fold, if you are anxious, because you already have a certain response to uncertainty that feels very physical, regardless of whether something is actually wrong. You already feel a million gut feelings every day just because of your anxiety that's shooting in many directions. When superstition is added in, we can make some incorrect calls. all in the name of trying to predict an outcome, trying to keep ourselves really safe. And I think that helps explain why superstitions can feel so compelling. Even when rationally, again, rationally, we know that these two things are probably not linked.
Having a rabbit's foot in your car and being able to drive safe, like those things are rationally not linked. The conscious mind probably knows, but another part of our mind says maybe they're not linked. there's no evidence, but why risk it? From an evolutionary perspective, it was and is still safer to overreact to possible danger than to ignore something that might matter or might protect us. Superstitions grow in that space. They grow in that space between intuition and uncertainty where, again, the brain would rather do something symbolic or that it thinks might help than sit passively, not knowing and not being able to do anything. The only thing our can do in moments of uncertainty is just to kind of wait and see, or we can try out this cool
little ritual. A pretty notable paper from back in 1994 found that magical thinking increases under high stress conditions, especially among people with lower tolerance of uncertainty. Researchers asked, I think it was like 174 participants to basically complete questionnaires about magical thinking and intolerance to ambiguity. All of these people, by the way, were living in war zones during the Gulf War and they were either exposed to regular missile strikes, so that was a high stress condition or not exposed, low stress condition. What the research has found was that participants in the high stress condition who were actively living in a war zone, basically, were more likely to engage in magical thinking compared to those who weren't. Because under these
situations where so little was in their control, they couldn't determine where a bomb or where a missile was going to drop and where it wasn't. They weren't in control of the political forces that be the only thing the mind could reach for was symbolic control and was these superstitious beliefs that doing certain things might protect them, not doing certain things might leave them at risk. This is such an important point. Superstition is often about fear management as this example shows. Psychological research proves that tiny actions regulate emotions precisely because they are tiny, because they are doable. And this ritualized behavior can counteract our anxieties about bigger things. These ritualized four-leaf clover, knock-on wood, evil eye behaviors are powerful in that
manner. Researchers from Harvard actually demonstrated this further in a 2016 paper where they got basically participants who engaged in rituals, so a sequence of symbolic actions that were very repetitive, very formal, when they did this before stressful tasks, it actually improved their performance. This goes to show something very important. Superstition is a form of emotional regulation. Displaying the evil lie, knocking on wood, may not actually change your luck, but it changes your emotional state to feel more in control. That is actually what influences the outcome. Because somebody who is calmer can also think rationally, can problem solve better, will have a better outcome. That is the power of the superstitious belief. So do superstitions
actually change outcomes? The answer is sometimes yes, but not in the way that you would expect. We're going to discuss all of that and more after this short break. With four nights at residents in downtown Montreal, flights from Porter Airlines, two weekend gold tickets, and $1,000 of cash. Please love it. Lord, Zara Larson, Dave McRae, Sombor, 21 pilots, and more. Download I-Heart Radio, listen to I-Heart new music for 10 minutes, and enter to win. Oceaga, 2026. Every day you listen is another chance to win.
In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir.
Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape and murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so. People wake up. I'm the one that saw them. murder take place by crevette and de pippo.
Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to LaVa for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people. Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult.
There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And it's a ton of exciting because their new star
is Javier Cichorito Hernandez. He's from Mexico he's going to push it. Everyone sees me as a football
player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems,
mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from?
What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa?
From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table, and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has an order perfect and everything is just.
Wait, me, I'm going to be able to be able to be. We are here to connect. The Chicharito. I'm Javier El Chicharito-Randes, and together with Ica Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
Mainstream media is full of crude depictions of the unhoused, stories that shame and blame and paint the unhoused as a monolith. We The UnHouse is the podcast that's changing that. I'm Theo Henderson, creator and host, and for years I've created a space where the unhoused and their advocates can tell their own stories. In the last few months alone, I've interviewed unhoused parents, immigrants, mutual aid organizers, veterans, the LGBTQTIA plus community, and the policymakers who make the laws that impact the unhoused existence. Whedian Houses a two-time Webby and Signal Award-winning show with many exciting guests on the horizon. Tune in this week for my interview with Dr. Gio which are a street doctor turned influencer whose work with the unhoused community has made a huge
impact online and in her community listen to weelian housed on the iHeard radio app apple podcast or wherever you get your podcast superstitious people i think often get a bad rap like we've explored why they come to develop these rituals me being one of those people i think we get a bad rap for being irrational and for being a little bit woo-woo or maybe not the sharpest tools in the shed or being just anxious people who want and need anything to make us feel better. I think that is a way too simplistic perspective and it overlooks some very deep, deep facts about human psychology and human behavior. Yes, in a sense, it is irrational to believe in something that's not evidence-based. But that doesn't mean that rituals do nothing. As I said right before
this break, they do and can and will continue to create a bit of a self-fulfilling prophecy effect. And here is how. There is a heavily cited paper from researchers at the University of Cologne published in 2010 that found engaging in some kind of good luck superstition, improved performance on tasks involving motor skills, memory, and persistence. In part, because you know, doing or performing a superstitious ritual increased an individual self-efficacy, i.e. their belief that they could execute the behaviors necessary to change the outcome themselves. The lucky charm, the behavior, the ritual made them calmer and gave them confidence to try something, anything, compared to a previous situation where fear made them do nothing. And that ability or just,
that slight course change towards doing something, that is. what changed the outcome. I think it's kind of like when children bring their favorite stuff toy to school with them. Do you remember that when you were a kid in the first couple weeks you got to bring your toy to help us like settle in? The toy doesn't change anything about the environment apart from the fact that it makes it more comfortable and the positive associations the toy has induces a psychological effect in that it improves our mood and improves our emotions and makes us feel like we can cope. This helps, explain why athletes, performers, musicians, so often develop superstitions and rituals in high
pressure domains, uncertainties everywhere. You can train for years and still have an off day, still have a weird feeling, still blank, still have somebody throw something at you, yell at you, people create routines around their performances, the same warm up, the same meal, the same playlist, the same socks, the same sequence of things. Because, consciously or even consciously, it helps them manage the anxiety that things could go wrong. It helps them feel more in control of things that they're not in control of. The ritual is less about luck. I think that's the first thing we think.
We think that it's changing somebody's luck or they think it's changing their luck. No, it's more about crossing this important mental threshold. It tells the body, it tells the mind that we're safe, we've done everything we can, and it enters them into a performance state. makes them feel prepared and in control for this big moment. There is also a social layer to superstition that I think people often underestimate. So many superstitions and rituals when you break it down are culturally inherited. They are ways of staying connected to family, heritage, ancestors in a way that makes us feel
supported, even in really hard situations. For example, in China, the number eight, the color red, considered very very important. lucky, considered a symbol that's going to bring wealth and happiness. This is a cultural-wide superstition. It's also deeply tied to business, to daily life, to significant celebrations. And I actually think a big role of superstition and why people are superstitious is because it's about belonging. Rituals can strengthen social identity and cohesion. And this sense that we are all held together in being guided or supported by something larger than ourselves. Studies on rituals, and particularly participation in superstitious rituals within a community,
have linked ritual engagement with increased social bonding, increased social well-being, and increased individual satisfaction, especially in communities where shared practices signal identity and mutual care. Think about it. Who is going to perform better during an exam or a game or a job interview? Someone who feels like they belong and have people believing in them, silently encouraging them, who has a superstition that connects them to those people,
or someone who feels the burden of going at it alone and who has nothing to relate to their community through. I think it's a common sense answer for most of us. So again, this is why superstitions are so effective psychologically. They make us feeling control. They unconsciously manage our emotional state for us. They have a form of anxiety management. And they connect us to something bigger than ourselves.
That is, again, very calming. Is there a downside? Yes, of course there is. There always is. Firstly, the biggest downside of superstitions that we need to talk about, the same thing that pushes people towards superstitions during uncertain times is also what drives people towards conspiracies. Conspiracies are a similar form of what psychologists call compensatory control. When things feel unsafe, we want an explanation and we want someone else or something else
to blame the same way that we want to think that something else gives us luck. Think about time periods when superstitions and conspiracies have been the most ripe. During the Black Plague, during the Salem witch trials, after 9-11, during COVID. What is something that all those things have in common? They were very, very uncertain times. Very scary things were happening that threatened our individual sense of safety. And so people flock, once again, to things that they think are an explanation or could provide a rational explanation or could provide a rational cause and effect, even when there isn't
any evidence for it, just because they are seeking anything. They're looking for any answer, anything that could help them, anything that could ward off a bad spirit, anything that could explain a situation so that it is more manageable to them emotionally and mentally. Superstitions can also, alongside that, become something that is very individually punishing rather than helpful when they become negative rather than positive. And I think here is a very good place to make the distinction between positive and negative superstitions because they are very different. Positive superstitions are usually organized around luck, hope, the possibility that
something really good is going to happen. These are the rituals and beliefs that people use to invite success, confidence, protection in uncertain situations, good fortune. Psychologically, these superstitions do often function as a form of emotional and psychological support. In that sense, as we've explored, positive superstitions are often less about fear, the more about comfort. They help people approach challenging situations with a stronger sense of agency, a stronger sense of control, hope, structure. Negative superstitions tend to work very differently. These, These are often built less around attracting luck, more around avoiding danger, warding off bad outcomes, protecting yourself from the unknown.
The emotional tone here is threat-based. Rather than the superstition offering encouragement, these superstitions can increase vigilance, fear, avoidance, maybe even guilt. If something bad happens and then you find out that there was a superstition all along that you shouldn't have done something, they're often bound up with the idea that something bad could happen if you get it wrong, which makes them feel psychologically heavier and more significant. It feels there's more of an urgency to perform them. That is why negative superstitions can become more time consuming or just mentally consuming compared to positive ones, because we are pulled into this preventative, anxious mindset,
that there is something we must do to avoid bad luck. we must do so that the bad thing doesn't happen to us. Research has again found meaningful differences between people who are more likely to lean towards positive versus negative superstitions. Specifically, people who are more drawn towards negative superstitions are more likely to have severe anxiety, more likely to have a fear or what we call an intolerance for uncertainty, and typically have a higher sensitivity to threat. Similar papers have also found that negative superstitions may be more likely to be repeated
on an obsessive scale. Why? Simply because, again, they are threat-based. Not doing them makes us feel like something bad is going to happen. And our brain pays more attention to the possibility of bad things happening over good things happening. Hence, they capture more of our attention purely from this ancient survival mechanism point of view.
the greater the imagined danger, the heart of the ritual is to dismiss. And I think this is an important caveat because this is when superstitions start to more from a playful habit, a social habit, and closer to a more threat-driven coping strategy where the person is no longer asking, could this help me, but can I afford not to do this thing? So this is when we need to talk about a very, one specific mental condition in particular that does not mix very favourably with superstitious rituals. I'm going to give you a chance to guess what that may be. OCD, obsessive compulsive disorder. Superstitions quickly become very complicated and sometimes genuinely risky for people with OCD because they overlap with the same, I guess the same
core logic that often drives obsessive behaviours. The same thing that drives people to check locks multiple times, to obsessively clean their hands, to excessively ruminate over the same thought again and again again, also drives superstitious beliefs, and that is namely magical thinking. Magical thinking sounds very fun, doesn't it? Very whimsical. Magical thinking, very magical. It's not. With OCD, it is the sense that a thought image feeling, word, small action can influence an outcome in a way that it is not
realistically connected to. So for example, someone might fear that they, like if they don't tap a door frame exactly five times in a specific place before leaving the house, everybody and their family is going to die. They may believe that having a violent intrusive thought somehow increases the chance that that's going to come true. They're superstitious mentally. So many. So many. Somebody might believe that, you know, if they don't say a prayer a certain way or do a certain ritual a certain way, bad things will happen to them. The central idea is very similar to superstition, if not the same. It's that you may be able to influence an outcome through an unrelated act, if only you know about it, if only you are part of the group who
understands the superstition. And just like superstition, compulsions are often, again, attempts to cope with the discomfort, the human discomfort of not knowing. They are ways of trying to prevent harm, create certainty, neutralized danger, and therefore feel temporarily safe. The problem is, because I don't think superstitions are the problem, the problem is that in OCD, this never actually resolves the fear. It just teaches the brain that the ritual mattered, that the threat must have been real, and that uncertainty isn't tolerable. This is the interesting thing, right? You perform the ritual, you do the compulsion, the bad thing doesn't happen, but you have no way of knowing whether the bad thing wasn't going to happen all along,
because now you can't stop performing the ritual. One time there's been this coincidence that you've done this thing and the bad thing hasn't happened. In the mind of somebody with OCD, that is an amazing thing to cling on to. We're just constantly looking for anything that can tell us or give us a sense that we can control what is uncontrollable. For somebody who's just superstitious, these things are kind of fine, fun, light, enjoyable. For somebody with OCD, a superstitious belief or ritual or activity or routine,
to them it is life and death. It cannot be ignored. I remember for me, I used to have to stare at the sun once a day when I was a kid to make sure it wasn't going to explode. And if I didn't look at the sun, well, everybody was cursed. Completely irrational. So irrational. But I did some very serious damage to my eyes because of that. And it's just a part of superstition and its interaction with OCD we need to be aware of. Similar process can happen with anxiety. People with high anxiety are often especially sensitive again to uncertainty, superstition, superstitions are extra appealing because they offer a quick sense of structure, something to put
into action that they can do right now. Instead of sitting with the distress of not knowing, instead of seeing how things may play out, the anxious mind gets to do something. So then in that moment, yeah, the superstition, the belief, the ritual does reduce the intensity of the anxiety. That makes it more likely to be repeated, but you never get to see what's on the other side of if you didn't perform the superstition. Even if somebody doesn't, even if they don't rationally think that this ritual is doing anything, it becomes what we call a maladaptive coping mechanism. So whilst superstition and OCD or anxiety related behaviors are not the same thing, they do rest on similar psychological foundations. One of the clearest, clearest differences
and ways for you to tell if it's something you're worried about is how the behavior feels. If the behavior is flexible, occasional, more lighthearted than it is distressing, it's more likely to be an ordinary ritual or an ordinary superstition. But if it starts to feel rigid, urgent, exhausting, or impossible to resist, if you feel like you have to do it, that may be a sign that something more than everyday superstition is going on. The same is true if the ritual keeps expanding. If one rule turns into many or if the relief never really lasts for that long, that is a sign that your superstition is becoming its own unmanageable beast.
And if that's the case, like that's when you do need professional help. Because it is very much manageable. That's the thing. Superstitions or magical thinking is manageable. You just need somebody who can guide you through it. And again, not all superstitions are going to turn out that way. Not all people who are superstitious have OCD or have a need. intense anxiety. It is just one link and one relationship that is just important to be aware of.
Okay, we are going to take one more short break, but when we return, let's go back towards the positives of superstition and rituals and talk about why having superstitions and habits maybe is important in our 20s. Maybe is something that more of us should be looking to adopt. Stay with us. Toronto. Pride is an opportunity for you to create your own space, to celebrate your existence. Iheart Radio is proud to be an official sponsor of Pride Toronto Festival and we won't stop. Celebrate Pride. Turn up the love and listen to IHeart Pride Canada.
Your 24-7 radio stream and the only playlist you need for your Toronto Pride celebrations. Pride is so great because it gives a whole bunch of people this visibility that they've never had before. We have a ton to celebrate Toronto. Happy Pride. IHeart Radio. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified.
There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a young 12-year-old child.
She's as bad as it gets. I would think so. People wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place. by crevette and de pippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty.
I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to Lobba for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101, Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges.
I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Everyone star is Jeterito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born.
And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa?
From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table, and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has a order perfect and everything is just.
Wait me, I'm going to pressur me, but me will go to be able to be able to be connect. The Chicharito. Oh, Javier El Chicholito, and together with IHard Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It is a carac. Wow.
Listen to learning to be human on AHA Radio. Apple Podcast or wherever you get your podcast. Keith Giamanka seemed like a mild-mannered suburban dad, but secretly, he became someone else, a master of disguise who went on a crime spree. At the time, did it seem like a crazy idea? It seemed very crazy, but I felt so desperate that I felt it was the quickest, easiest way out.
Did you allow yourself to think about how it could go wrong on what that might look like. No, I didn't want to manifest that. I was trying to manifest success. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. This is going to change my life and my family dynamic forever, because everything that had
existed prior in my reality is now untrue. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think we all need more rituals. Superstitious or not. A hill I will die on. Humanity is sadder and less connected because we no longer have the same spiritual practices we're used to. Now let me say this, because people always get mad when I talk about the importance of spirituality. But there are some very, very scary, sad, destructive parts about religion.
No denying religion has a very terrible history for many people. But one thing most major religions did get right was that humans feel better when they have a practice like prayer, when they have a practice like visiting an altar, like saying grace, specific traditions they can return to. It provides a much-needed center for people. It provides, once more, something they can control when life is on. certain. So when we talk about why superstitions and rituals matter so much, especially in our 20s, I think the answer is because this is the decade where we are most often asked to create stability without actually being given very much of it externally. We are in probably peak
uncertainty times right now. Your 20s are just full of just everything could go wrong, everything may be going wrong. And you're just trying to figure it out. You're trying to figure out what you actually care about. You're trying to make choices without complete information. You're trying to build a life whilst probably still grieving the life you had only a few years ago. You are changing at such a rapid rate. You literally, some days you think you know everything about yourself. The next day you know absolutely nothing. Some days you love your friends. The next days you feel lonely. Some days you feel great about your career the next day. You have no clue how you're going to do this for the rest of your life. This is an incredibly psychologically intense thing to live through for anybody.
Rituals and superstitions become important during this time because, much like the spiritual rituals we spoke about before, they become this grounding force to return to. They're always going to be there. They are stable. They are consistent. Wearing the same earrings to every job interview. Wearing red on your first dates. Saying a mantra to yourself every morning before you walk out the door.
watching the same movie every year on your birthday to ensure that you have good luck for the year ahead is a powerful form of uncertainty management in an uncertain time, even if it's a very, very small thing to do. Here are some other superstitions, superstitious of rituals, I should say, that you guys provided that I think maybe something you want to consider doing in your life. You guys, the listeners, wrote in with these, thank you for your contributions. let me read some of them out. Okay, are you guys ready?
Always sitting in the same seat at the movie cinema. Love that one. This one comes from Maggie. Keeping every single birthday card you receive because throwing them out would mean such would signify that you want that relationship with that person to end. I will be doing that one.
Again, superstitious. I want my relationships to be good and healthy. That seems like a smart way to do it. This person says, I cut my hair off after making a big, decision to signify such prove to the universe, God, the world question mark, that I'm serious about it. Not telling anyone good news until it absolutely is confirmed. I do this one. My mom was such a big believer in this when we were growing up, so I will continue to do this. I reread old
journals every single new year so that I don't have to repeat the same lessons twice. Watching the sunrise every year on my birthday. I love this one. You guys know, I do this, such a version of this. Always donating the first $10 of every paycheck to show abundance and that I am protected and supported enough by the universe that I can give money away. Having cold showers on the first day of every single month in brackets, I have never missed a month for five years. Crazy. Another one that I love. My friend Erica actually keeps wine bottles from important meals in her life as a way to just kind of show gratitude. And I don't know why she does it.
I think it's like a superstition that like if she doesn't keep these bottles, it shows that she's not grateful and she won't have more nights like that. So it's like a gratitude practice of like collecting and a gratitude practice of keeping mementos. Those are just some examples that you guys sent in. Sometimes again, like I love these. They're not always about superstition. then are always about luck. I think a lot of them are about faith and they're about repetition
and they're about control. Again, not necessarily religious faith, but faith in the broader sense, faith that this moment we're in means something, that you can do hard things, that you are protected in some small way, that hope is still allowed, that there is a meaning in the mystery of life, and that you are in control, that you get to come back to the things that are important. to you and you have a way of, I guess, managing the unexpected. I think there's something very beautiful about this that we kind of need now more than ever, yes, during our 20s, but also just in this weird time of humanity. We talk about superstition as if it's silly or embarrassing or something to grow out of. But I do think a lot of the time, again, thinking of those examples,
what we are really doing is creating our own magic, creating our own alchemy. We are taking an ordinary moment, an ordinary object, an ordinary routine, and saying, this matters to me, therefore it must matter full stop. This helps me. This makes me feel brave. This gives me a small point of steadiness. It doesn't matter if it does or doesn't based on the evidence. It's important to me. And studies have shown that people who do have rituals, who do have routine, who do have superstitions, a belief system, grounding habits are happier, they're more well adjusted, and ultimately they feel more capable of handling difficult things because they have coping measures, because they have something that redefines their self-efficacy.
That is one of the most human things about us. We are actually not just creatures of logic. We are creatures of meaning. It doesn't matter that these things are irrational. It's why we make art. It's why we sing songs. It's why we are superstitious. It's why superstitions show up in every single,
culture in the world, why they are part of humanity. We want to believe in something bigger, and we want to believe that there is something significant in the small things that we do. That is psychologically important in a way that doesn't always make sense, but just happens to be true. So that is the psychology of superstition. I hope you enjoy this episode. As a little summary before I say goodbye to you, superstition is in every single culture in the world because it says something really, really important about our emotional and psychological state as humans, which is that we like order, we like structure, we like feeling that we are in control. When we are faced with uncertain things, believing that a four-leaf clover gives you good
luck, even though it's just a clover, believing that knocking on wood somehow protects you, even though there's no science to that, it's anxiety management, it's fear management, it's emotional regulation and I think one that is overlooked far too often. Superstitions definitely can go a little bit off the rails, especially when they get mixed up in conspiracy theories and in OCD and anxiety, but ultimately they are very, very valuable. And if they are not hurting anybody, there is probably a chance that they are helping you because it brings back a sense of agency. It means that you feel, I don't know,
safe enough to actually do something rather than nothing, and therefore does create self-fulfilling prophecies. As we've seen from these examples, it does end up changing outcomes for people, not because what they did actually mattered, but because what it made them feel and what it then allowed them to do. So there we go. The psychology of superstition. I hope you enjoy this episode. If you have made it this far and you were listening on Spotify, leave a little comment down below. what is a superstitious belief that you have? I was just saying to a friend of mine, my belief, and this is like totally not related to my life right now, people are going to be like, oh my God, she's going to have a baby. But no, I really believe that before, like, if you're
pregnant slash expecting a child, you should not bring any like baby stroller, baby crib into the house before the child is born. Don't know why, but I am so superstitious about it. And I think when I have kids, I will not be doing that. I think it's something like an old wives tale that my mom told me. So share yours down below. Thank you as always to our amazing researcher Libby Kobe for her assistance and help with this episode. You can also watch this episode and many others on Netflix. Check it out. Go have a look. It's really cool. You can follow us on Substack. You can also follow us on Instagram if you want more visual summaries of episodes just like this one. There's all the stuff in the description, including some of our favorite
sources from this episode so go check it out but with all that in mind be safe be kind be a little bit superstitious and be gentle to yourself we will talk very very soon there was no anything inside those eyes they turned black it scared the hell out of me people wake up i'm the one that saw the murder take place by crevette and de pippo anthony de pippo showed no signs of remorse a appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Joy is essential, and it's also elusive, but now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS.
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is a spontaneous, and genuine, just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tchariot Hernandez and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts,
or whatever you get your podcast. Your husband is not who you think he is. Your body is not what you thought it was. Your identity is formed by a secret history. I'm Danny Shapiro. And these are just a few of the stunning stories I'll be exploring on the 14th season of Family Secrets. He kind of shoved me out of the way and said, move. And he went out the front door and he jumped in a car and drove off.
And that was the last time I saw him. Listen to season 14 of Family Secrets on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. Is everyone lying to me about who they are? I felt such desperation. I felt it was what I had to do.
Listen to deep cover the family man on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.